aujourd'hui plus que jamais la pression
sur le gouvernement pour accélérer les
distributions de doses de vaccin est
maximale
mais comment le gouvernement va-t-il
faire pour obtenir ces objectifs compte
tenu que le vaccin astrazeneca est
aujourd'hui suspendu pour une durée
indéterminée
la décision qui a été prise c'est de
suspendre par précaution la vaccination
avec astrazeneca et les clairement la
stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement pour
rejoindre des pays comme le royaume uni
qui a déjà vacciné 37 % de sa population
contre 7% en france enfin la france
d'aujourd'hui face à un nouveau variant
le variant breton indétectable avec un
test pcr il pourrait compliquer la lutte
contre la propagation de la commune en
france
alors que faire ce soir-là ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie agnès
pannier-runacher est avec nous et elle
va répondre à toutes vos questions
et j'aimerais que vous posez vos
questions également sur les réseaux
sociaux a les idées chéri on est en
direct qui font profiter 20 ans 11 merci
agnès pannier rue nash et d'être avec
nous ministre délégué chargé de
l'industrie on verra pas de membres du
gouvernement
demain matin dans les émissions ni ce
soir à parlant castex tout al heure plus
tard sur bfm déjà merci pour votre
courage de venir en direct à chaque fois
c'est vrai que ça va être compliqué
d'avoir des questions et il nous faut
des réponses
est ce que on a bien fait est ce que le
gouvernement a bien fait de suspendre le
vaccin astrazeneca
oui il a bien fait parce que il ya de
l'inquiétude par rapport à ces quelques
cas de thrombose donc la thrombose pour
faire simple c'est surtout la phlébite
ça me connaît mieux et ce alors on va on
va rappeler ce que c'est horrible qu'ils
bougent ouais une veine qui font
exactement voilà les caillots sanguins
voilà qui se fond voilà et donc notre
ligne constante c'est sécurité et
transparence sécurité on se doit de
protéger les français qui vont être
vaccinés lors des années le meilleur
vaccin transparence à chaque fois que ya
peut-être un indice une alerte ou une
inquiétude nous le voulons crayon nous
vérifions qu'il n'y a pas de difficultés
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire sur
les quelques cas qui sont concernées dit
où agnès la madame la ministre mady
espagne orange chez moi j'ai vu plein de
gens aujourd'hui qu'il dise on est quand
même les champions du monde ont choisi
un vaccin on voit qu'il est pas bon
comment ça se fait alors il ya trois
vaccins aujourd'hui en france il y en a
deux qui sont parfaitement bien et y en
a un sur lequel on fait juste une
vérification il ya 15 millions de
personnes en europe qui ont été
vaccinées à l'astra zeneca 15 millions
de personnes vous avez une cinquantaine
de cas de thrombose qui sont arrivés à
peu près au moment de la vaccination
simplement dans sa stricte et les jours
vous avez plus près 300 thrombose ça
arrive ça arrive ça arrive tout de suite
après ces quatre tombeau juste après la
vaccination c'est avec quelques jours
après quand on fait un suivi très précis
et on regarde s'il ya des
maladie des phénomènes des effets
secondaires qui arrive quelques heures
ou quelques jours après la vaccination
juste pour s'assurer chaque moment que
les vaccins sont parfaitement sécurisés
et donc là on a plutôt d'ailleurs dans
les pays du nord si aucun cas en france
quelques dossiers qui nous font remonter
et on dit on va regarder justement tous
les toutes les toutes les personnes qui
nous regardent qui se sont fait vacciner
avec ce vaccin astrazeneca comme
géraldine maillet elle nous l'a dit ce
week-end est-ce qu'ils doivent craindre
des effets secondaires ou est-ce qu'au
bout de quelques jours vous avez vu que
normalement si on fait pas de thrombose
dans les voiles artisans fr on est
sorties d'affaires
voilà géraldine maillet par exemple est
sorti d'affaires surtout je le redis 15
millions de personnes entre le royaume
uni et l'europe et 54 thrombose donc
c'est extrêmement rare et la deuxième
chose c'est que aujourd'hui on n'a pas
établi de lien entre la vaccination et
ces cas là mais on veut juste avoir le
l'assurance et pour les personnes qui
sont vaccinées moi mes parents sont
vaccinés à l'astra zeneca depuis
mercredi
vous êtes vous avez vous savez ce que
vous avez une petite race rare le
franchement agnès moi si je suis pas
inquiète du touran ils ne sont pas
inquiet du tout et je peux vous dire que
ils sont surtout soulagé d'avoir eu
leurs premières doses alors 20 minutes
juste pour savoir
là il ya un autre problème qui va se
poser c'est 11 il y avait quand même
énormément de doses d'astrazeneca qui
vont être pour l'instant me stocker
est-ce que déjà on peut les stocker ce
qu'on allait
les doses astrazeneca c'est ce stock au
réfrigérateur donc en difficulté ça ça
m'a choqué mais ça va ralentir tout la
vaccination pas nécessairement parce que
si nous avons une décision de l'autorité
de l'agencé du médicament européenne
jeudi d'accord à reprendre la
vaccination confiante sur cette décision
oui parce que l' agence du médicament a
fait aujourd'hui une conférence de
presse en étant plutôt positif en étant
même très positives et en disant qu'elle
allait continuer à analyser la situation
mais pour le moment elle avait pas
d'indications négatives sur le vaccin
j'ai entendu le patron d'astrazeneca je
cite était sur la sellette qu'en pensez
vous oui je pense que le sujet que nous
avons avec l'entreprise astrazeneca si
elle ne respecte pas son contrat de
livraison ça c'est un autre sujet bien
sûr elle ne respecte pas son contrat
livraison
elle devait livrer des millions de doses
elle n'en livre que 25% une dose sur
quatre bateaux et là c'est pas ok pour
nous et donc le sujet c'est de dire que
nous voulons des explications un plan de
correction
et c'est d'autant plus important que
nous avons grosso modo le même contrat
que les britanniques et que les
britanniques sont livrés on a les mêmes
clauses on l'a signé un prix au même
prix grosso modo aux mêmes prix - tenons
ont même pris même klose même prix même
date de signature grosso modo on est un
jour avant eux et donc nous voudrons
être nous voulons être livré comme eux
c'est très simple justement comme neymar
mahagne espagnol d'achille à vous venez
de donner un exemple et là je connais
ils ont du mal à moi je vous dis tout un
évent devant leur aide ont leur poste
ils doivent se dire c'est pas possible
daikin n'est qu'un problème c'est pour
nous donc comment ça se fait comment ça
se fait que les britanniques soient
livrés sont livrés et pau nous qu'est ce
qui se passe on est en droit parce que
l'on est on est donc les autres les
banques alors mais moins la pression on
est qu'est ce qui se passe ou un payer
moins cher non mais c'est vrai je pose
la question parce que c'est incroyable
non mais c'est des très bonnes questions
il faut avoir en tête qu'aujourd'hui on
a eu plus de 50 millions de livraisons
de doses de vaccins en europe plus de 50
millions et nous allons avoir au total
sur le premier trimestre plus de 100
millions de doses de vaccins on et 450
millions en europe s'étonner quand même
nombreux on est un peu plus nombreux que
les anglais
au deuxième trimestre le commissaire
thierry breton table sur 300 millions de
livraisons de doses mais pourquoi les
ongles ils ont été livrés pas nu parce
qu'ils sont à ça c'est spécifiquement
sur le cadastre à zenica vous êtes jolie
alors on peut donner plus d'argent que
vous avez d'autres d'autres vaccins sur
le cac d'astrazeneca astrazeneca c'est
une entreprise qui est britannique que
ça tu es suédois lasse donc est bon ils
ont des rockies ont et c'est la
recherche du lab de l'université
d'oxford et l'exercice est important
c'est la recherche anr sur leur a permis
de titres et brigitte 0e brigitte un
européen des vaccinations c'est qu'ils
ont été évidemment ils ont fait la
préférence d'assurer dès gens sachent
juste qu'est ce que vous pensez un
espagnol si vous êtes un petit peu
madame vaccin aussi un voilà du duduk du
gouvernement les vaccins le vaccin russe
le vaccin russe aujourd'hui il vient de
déposer sont aussi à l'autorisent à l'
agence du médicament européenne
donc on va faire son analyse un agent ça
sert son analyse et s'il respecte les
conditions de sécurité et d'efficacité
on lui donnera une autorisation de mise
sur le marché
après ce qu'il faut savoir sur ce vaccin
c'est qu'en fait il est un peu complexes
à fabriquer quand il a des problèmes
d'industrialisation deux fois - bruce
sont vaccinés que d'européens en
proportion de la population poussée avec
5 à l'air plutôt bien on va en avoir la
vérification dans l'eure l'eure dans les
semaines qui viennent mais ya pas
beaucoup de doses et nous sommes en
train d'essayer de voir avec les rues si
on peut trouver un moyen mais aidé à
industrialiser leur production des
vaccins encore pourquoi le pourquoi le
vaccin le finder est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher que l'astra zeneca
parce que c'est une nouvelle technique
la rn message et on n'a jamais fait de
vaccins arn messagers de cette ampleur
on l'a fait en recherche mais jamais
pour le grand public et donc je de même
que
le moderna les prix sont à peu près
qu'on se soit rabat et ré message et
dorian weiser parce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui ce qui est dingue
même dans le milieu des vaccins
maintenant il ya un côté snobisme
voilier recoller mais quid maintenant
c'est comme moi par iphone 12 mois je me
suis fait vacciner fighters la raison
tout cas non mais c'est vrai c'est
incroyable donc ça c'est fou aussi de
voir on est on est dans une telle crise
et aujourd'hui il ya même des
différences
voilà mine de rien avec de ceux qui se
font vacciner entre tous qui seront
vaccinés vraiment qu'il a le droit ou
pfizer
ces personnes de plus de 75 ans d'accord
c'est les personnes qui présentent ce
qu'on appelle des comorbidités c'est à
dire qui en gros même si elles sont plus
jeunes à risque doit faire une version
très grave du virus pour qu'on n'a pas
commandé que des paysans parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas capables de fabriquer
beaucoup plus on est complètement au
taquet de la fabrication et du retour
aussi parce que l'enjeu
l'enjeu on a commandé lui vaccin
aujourd'hui et l'enjeu c'était d'avoir
le maximum de vaccins possible de
candidats vaccins qui réussissent et
capable d'avoir le maximum de doses
livrées sur le marché
quand on commande en juin juillet on n'a
aucun élément sur la réussite du vaccin
sur l'humain on n'a que des modèles
animaux on n'a que des essais à un stade
très peu avancé
donc on fait un pari est donc on appris
de manière systématique les vaccins qui
avait la présentation scientifique la
plus rigoureuse et qui était susceptible
d'arriver plus rapidement sur le marché
on a été et on est comme les américains
on allait même vaccin que les américains
les mêmes vaccins que les anglais et
pourquoi on voudrait bien pourquoi les
israéliens alors que pfizer est aussi
vite
ils ont fait le choix de donner leurs
données
individuels personnels de santé dans un
pays comme la france quand on voit le
débat qui a suscité par exemple
l'application tous sentis provident ne
paraissait pas tout à fait atteignable
alors amis espagnols une hache et une
autre question que les gens se posent
aussi c'est on voit que c'est une course
contre la montre
parce que là il ya des variants qui
arrivent tous les jours est ce que on a
rattrapé un peu notre temps au niveau
des vaccins où on est toujours à la
ramasse
donc je pense qu'on est pas si mal
positionné que ça même si on a tous
envie d'être vaccinés on a tous envie de
sortir la tête de l'eau on va pas se
raconter d'histoires la sacem avec même
avec cette histoire d'astrazeneca
prologis parce que je vais partir de la
semaine prochaine on va avoir des
livraisons importantes notamment du
vaccin
by one tech riser on va en avoir encore
un peu près à millions 1,9 donc de
personnes vaccinées aujourd'hui en
france 7 millions 5,5 grand quiz
merci vous savez mieux kaminis n'hésitez
pas les voir juste ce variant breton n'a
entendu parler d'un variant breton ce
matin il faut s'en inquiéter ou pas
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas dire s'il est
plus ou moins dangereux ou plus ou moins
contagieux que les versions on connaît
aujourd'hui du duc au vide qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire on suit ça très près on
surveille on analyse et on est en train
de récupérer toutes les données
sanitaires des personnes qui ont ce
variant breton mais c'est assez courant
pour un virus d'avoir des mutations sur
vous savez que pour la grippe chaque
année il ya l'intégration alors suivre
au niveau des vaccins niveau de la
composition des vaccins avec tia dévoila
alors pas ce qu'on me dit voilà que le
variant onglets par exemple on l'a vu il
est beaucoup plus virulent que oui mais
alors il est pas plus virulent les plus
contagieuses
il a priori plus contagieux on sait pas
trop s'il est tellement plus con c'est
ce qu'on dirait roland laurière pas
complètement les chiffres ce qu'on sait
c'est que les vaccins sont efficaces sur
le variant angles est d'accord parce que
c'est des petites mutation donc les
vaccins avec général peuvent attraper
les petites mutations qu'il ya peut-être
des mutations qui seront plus
importantes et là on fera évoluer les
vaccins c'est ce qu'on fait sur la
grippe chaque année 1 chaque année vous
avez un nouveau vaccin de la grippe qui
est adapté aux variations du virus
lui-même d'accord oui de quelques une
dernière question il
il ya un million de fois sur une
personne connue de la première dose
d'une lettre à zenica imaginons que une
fois retirés du marché
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces gens qui ont
des premières doses et qui n'auront pas
deuxième lot témoin quand j'écoute l'
agence du médicament européenne j'ai pas
l'impression du tout que c'est la
direction que les sciences importante
dans le vaccin donc pour l'instant
l'hypothèse centrale
c'est quand même qu'on continue à
vacciner mais peut-être y aura des
précautions qui seront prises pour
certaines personnes qui auraient
certaines pathologies
ça c'est ce que va nous dire l'agencé du
médicament jeudi agnès pannier d'urines
hachez le
le couvre-feu à 18h le confinement le
week-end dans la région
ça porte ses fruits pour l'instant ou
pas du tout ben vous avez vu que nous
sommes un des rares pays qui n'a pas eus
ar confiné de manière générale et on est
quasiment le seul pays des grands pays
européens qui a ces écoles qui
fonctionne depuis le début de l'année
scolaire et qu'il n'a pas eu à les
fermer
et je n'ai pas le droit de vous parler
d'un reconfirme en ile-de-france bas à
ce stade soit compensé les doigts c'est
une réunion qui se tiendra demain vous
comme ça à vue de nez on va le confiner
ou pas 9e le même le week-end le
week-end non non non non non non bon
alors il ya le porte parole de tous
merci agnel sur tout cas je vous demande
pas de répondre à ça